Last week, I talked about the composition and origins of the Earth's atmosphere.
We also briefly looked at how biological processes have created an atmosphere...
...that is conducive to terrestrial life.
Today, we'll look at where ozone is found, how it's formed, how it's destroyed...
...and the problems this may cause.
Finally, we'll look at what actions have been taken by governments...
...and international bodies to stop this destruction.
Let's concentrate first on the ozone layer, which was briefly covered in last week's lecture.
It's important because it acts as a shield,...
...protecting animal and plant life from harmful ultraviolet radiation.
There are actually two ozone layers:...
...one of them occurs in the stratosphere, the other in the troposphere.
The one in the stratosphere is by far the bigger of the two and is formed naturally.
The ozone layer in the troposphere is anthropogenic.
By this, I mean that the ozone that occurs in this layer has been produced by human activity.
What are the chemical processes that create ozone?
To start with, UV radiation splits an oxygen molecule into oxygen atoms.
Then, one of these atoms combines with another oxygen molecule to form an ozone molecule.
What's more, ozone is constantly being formed and destroyed;...
...a natural balance between the production and destruction of these molecules seems to exist.
This, however, has changed.
From the beginning of the 20th century onwards,...
...human industrial activity has upset this balance...
...by producing chlorine-based chemicals called chlorofluorocarbons,...
...more commonly abbreviated to CFCs.
These compounds have accelerated the destruction of the ozone layer,...
...especially in the polar regions.